أعلن اليوم أن الولايات المتحدة
تستهدف الشريان الرئيسي
للاقتصاد
الروسي ، فنحن نحظر جميع واردات النفط
والغاز والطاقة
الروسية ، مما يعني أن النفط الروسي لن يكون
مقبولاً في الموانئ الأمريكية وسيوجه الشعب الأمريكي
ضربة قوية أخرى  إلى آلة الحرب ،
هذه خطوة تحظى بدعم قوي من
الحزبين للكونغرس ،
وأعتقد أن البلد
الذي اتخذناه هذا القرار قد اتخذناه بالتشاور الوثيق
مع حلفائنا
وشركائنا في جميع أنحاء العالم خاصة
في أوروبا
لأن الرد الموحد على عدوان بوتين كان
له  كان تركيزي الأساسي
على إبقاء
كل
حلف الناتو وكل الاتحاد الأوروبي وحلفائنا
متحدين تمامًا ، ولم يكن هناك الكثير
من الاتفاق على أه سبل دعم
الشعب الأوكراني
على ضرورة مواكبة العقوبات
الاقتصادية بل وتكثيفها ،
ولكن  وسأحتاج أيضًا إلى
تجاوز الاعتماد على النفط والغاز الروسيين
ونحن نمضي قدمًا في
الخارج